That remember I was talking about house people that live in other people's
houses and don't know they're talking about the five top five scariest stopped,
top five scariest, scariest things caught on a GoPro camera.
And I was talking to my friend
and she was saying that she had a friend
in Chicago that was,
um, on, that was,
that was there in, in the, in the S she moved in,
I guess, in the summer. And she kept hearing like rats in the attic.
And then when it was cold out, there was still shuffling around. She was like,
I got to call somebody. She called the called the, uh,
police or somebody, or like the fireman or something like something's up there,
you know, some animals up there they're like animal control or something.
I'm like, well, why don't you try and go up there and look around. She was like,
Oh fine. So she put a selfie stick on the, put a, uh, an, uh,
a phone on the selfie stick to go take the picture,
took a few shots up in the attic and
brought the phone down and looked.
And there was a guy in the attic
dude.
There was a guy,
a man in the attic. Yeah.
We show we'll show the picture on the video podcast.
We maybe blur out the guy's face.
Apparently it was just some homeless guy that was like doing, he was like,
the cops came and was like, yeah, no, he does this. Oh, well how about keep him?
Yeah, I know he does this every time we let them out. Oh, really?
Keep him hold that guy.
Do you have cells put him in there?
Put them in the attic of the cop place of the prison.
I mean, so insane. Just
know what I would do squirt everywhere. If that happened to me,
I go like this. First of all, I go like this to the people. You want me to what?
Go up there and Snoop around. Hmm.
You must have me confused with Jason Statham.
What's your second option. This is what I do. They go like this. Well,
maybe you want to go up there. And I say, huh,
what's your second option. And they say, selfie stick with a cell phone.
And I go like this, convince me. And then they,
after they convinced me for a while, I go like, okay. And I do it.
And I take a few pictures. I bring the phone down.
And if I see the picture that the person showed me the other night of the guy
in the attic, that's when I release my bowels.
That's when I all over my Yeezys,
I go like this, I go like this. And then I bring the foam down, look at it.
And I say, I got to get new Yeezys. That's what I say immediately. Ah.
I got to get new Yeezys. And then I go, ah, and run out.
I don't get scared first. Oh,
my Jordans are Brown. Ah, and run away.
I go, Hey, when you get, Oh, Hey, when you get out of this attic,
you're going to have to watch her watch out. Or you gonna slip.
I should all the way down my stairs, down my stairs to the first level.
And then down to my driveway, I got all in my Aston Martin.
That's what I got my babies.
And I drove all the way to the police station and I all over there.